from formula Princeton and morning I
want to start by saying thank you to the
organizers for including me in this I
was going to say thank you for putting
my talk first but then I just found out
it was alphabetical I suppose I
shouldn't say I suppose there was a
moment where the alphabet izing idea was
floated and they didn't they didn't say
oh god that would put Botvinnik first
let's do something else so I suppose I'm
still grateful but in any case it's good
to see old friends and look forward to
meeting those of you I haven't haven't
met before yeah so so I work this
company called deep mind whose mission
is to solve artificial general
intelligence and I'm gonna tell you
about some work that I undertook around
the time I arrived there two years ago
but I want to put it in some context and
that'll that'll involve me telling you a
bit more about deep mind so around the
time that I arrived my new colleagues
there were celebrating the publication
of a nature paper in which they
described superhuman level performance
from from a deep learning system on on a
classic suite of old Atari games many of
you be familiar with this work and it
didn't take long before this was
followed up by the amazing work of David
solar and others on the game of Go and
which of course has continued to advance
in papers like this more recent one on
chess and other games by the way if you
if you don't know about these recent
developments in AI research and you're
curious I recommend this movie I just I
just watched it myself it was it's a
documentary that was put together by a
set of independent filmmakers it was
it's not like a it's not like a
promotional video for deep mine
it's quite excellent and quite uh you
know quite quite dumb gets into the
cultural issues in a very interesting
way so anyway I I joined the company
partially because I was excited about
the AI mission but I also looked at the
you know the technology that was being
applied and I thought gee you know this
is this is something that should be of
interest to people like me who want to
figure out how the brain works and how
the human mind works why why is it
relevant well if you know about the
technology and then it's kind of obvious
it's centers on deep neural networks
which while they're they don't attempt
to fit to fine grain biological details
are nonetheless broadly inspired by the
operation of biological neural networks
and perhaps more importantly
architectures that are very similar to
the ones used in the Atari work have
been applied quite recently to modeling
neural response properties and in the
ventral stream in the primate brain for
example and work by humans in DeCarlo
which many of you will know so
interesting connection there which has
to do with how neural systems do
representation learning but there's also
another side to this which is about what
drives the learning and that as many of
you will know involves advances in using
deep neural networks to do reinforcement
learning hence the name deep
reinforcement learning there's again
here a very close connection with
developments recent developments in in
neuroscience well not so recent actually
maybe over the last 20 years when could
say more and more solid connection has
been forged between computational
reinforcement learning and algorithms
based in particular on temporal
difference learning on the one hand and
dopaminergic learning mechanisms in in
the brain so I'm hoping that many if not
most of you are at least broadly
familiar with the dopamine story in
neuroscience but there's still more in
terms of you know what's here to be
interested in as a neuroscientist so the
the work that I just described used
mainly feed-forward networks that don't
have recurrent connections but there's
also been a lot of progress in at both
the deep mind and elsewhere in in
training recurrent neural net
works using deep reinforcement learning
so just to give one example this is just
a schematic way of showing a
convolutional neural network that's
outputting a value function and a policy
and we can unroll this thing in time to
show that it's a recurrent neural
network which therefore has memory and
you can use networks like this as people
that do you mind have done to navigate
mazes discover goals and then when you
respawn in a new location in this
previously unfamiliar maze you go right
to the goal tasks like that I think my
colleague Greg Wayne will talk a lot
about later this is directly germane to
neural models that address actual
biological brains in the sense that
recurrent networks have been applied in
the growing number of papers to to try
to understand how recurrent circuits and
the brain support things like working
memory and indeed reinforcement learning
mechanisms in that context these are
just you know emblematic figures from
from well-known papers so this this
connection between neuroscience relevant
ideas and AI tech at least a deep mind
was no coincidence the company was
founded on an idea that in fact if we
want to solve AGI it might be smart to
look at neuroscience so this is not a
coincidence it's part of the strategy
that we continue to apply at mine and
this is a paper that my colleagues and I
wrote recently for neuron trying to kind
of lay out our philosophy on that so
this is what I was excited about when I
arrived and what I continue to be
excited about but but even as the Atari
work was becoming more and more
well-known there were some voices of I'm
not sure if the right word is descent
but maybe concern in the cognitive
science and neuroscience community
perhaps the most salient example is
Brendan Lake who along with a few
well-known colleagues wrote a paper for
brain and behavioral sciences
specifically focusing on the Atari work
that came out
mind and suggesting that as amazing as
the results were they failed to
satisfyingly capture some fundamental
aspects of human intelligence even human
intelligence as expressed in the context
of video games so what they what they
pointed out was if you look at dqn which
is the deep learning architecture the
the deep RL architecture that had been
built at deep mind for atari games it it
becomes clear when you look at learning
curves the performance of this network
over the course of learning that it
requires a huge amount of data it really
has to it has to essentially play these
video games for a very long time before
it reaches those amazing superhuman
levels of of aptitude and in order to
make make this point more strongly
Brendan in this paper contrasted that
with his own performance on an Atari
game that he'd never played before game
called frostbite and you can see the
contrast is very striking only after a
few minutes of play Brendan was able to
get a respectable score on on this game
whereas dqn took millions and millions
of frames and thousands of walk clock
hours in order to get to a comparable
level so things have changed since the
paper was originally drafted the kinds
of techniques that are involved in dqn
have become more sample if it sample
efficient but it's still the case that
there's a salient mismatch here humans
are just a lot more efficient at
learning than these deep reinforcement
learning systems so why is this well
it's kind of obvious I think on
reflection why this is Brendan came to
frostbite this novel video game for him
with a lot of background knowledge first
of all he knew how to see whereas dqn
did not but let's put that part aside he
also had a lot of sort of domain
relevant past experience so you know he
he dealt with computers before he had
played games before he played video
games before he presumably knew what an
igloo is which is something that's
relevant to kind of figuring out what's
going on in frostbite
so not only did he have all this
background knowledge but he could
skillfully bring all this background
knowledge to bear in trying to figure
out what's going on in an efficient way
in this nominally new situation this new
game so what I what I'm gesturing toward
with that last comment is that not only
did he have background knowledge but
he'd also he also has the ability to
learn efficiently because he's learned
how to learn he's he's able to his past
experiences and allow him not only to
apply knowledge but to apply knowledge
in an efficient way he's he knows how to
learn a new video game so this term
learning to learn is not new it was
coined back in the 1940s biased I got a
psychologist named Harry Harlow and he
he operationalized it in a very clever
experiment with monkeys and he later
replicated this with young children and
I'm gonna use it as a kind of running
example so let me explain what he did so
he had a monkey in a cage with bars
where the monkey could reach reach
through and grab objects that were
placed in front of the cage and on each
trial in task Harlow put two objects in
front of the monkey and allowed the
monkey to pick up one and when the
monkey picked up that object it saw a
well that was underneath the object and
it discovered whether or not there was a
morsel of food in that well and then
after the if there was food there the
monkey who was allowed to partake and on
the next trial the objects were put back
in place either in the same positions or
left-right reversed and the whole
procedure repeated and it repeated for
six rounds so the monkey dealt with the
same two objects six times in a row but
then critically Harlow replaced those
two objects with two completely new
objects that presumably the monkey had
never seen and the whole process started
over and this was followed by yet
another pairing yet another pairing yet
another pair for hundreds of pairs
always six steps in each in each round
and across these pairs of objects there
was a simple rule which was that for any
pair of objects there was one object
that was good
arbitrarily chosen and the other object
was bad good men you got the food bad
you know and it doesn't matter where the
objects are spatially it's just the
identity of the object and what Harlow
reported is diagrammed here so this is
these are the six trials in each block
with each with each pair of objects and
on the y-axis is the percent of trials
at that step where the monkey chose the
right object the one that that Yul did
the food and you can see that over the
course of a block the monkey gets better
and better but that's a rather gradual
process early on the interesting thing
is what happens after the monkey has
done on the order of a hundred rounds of
the task and what you see then is shown
in pink here the monkey chooses one
object arbitrarily it can't do better
than that it doesn't know which the good
object is but on the second trial and
from there on the monkey is its ceiling
the monkey is essentially perfect and
that it doesn't matter whether the
monkey was rewarded on the first trial
or not it infers what the right object
is even though these are two objects
that it's never seen before so Harlow
coined the term learning to learn in
this context the monkey had you know so
to speak figured out what's going on in
this task and it understood the
invariance it understood the task
structure and was able to apply that in
learning about two new objects so you so
so let's talk about that later one
another I think another version of that
question is what's the difference
between learning and inference right I
think one reason I like this example is
that you have two completely new objects
so there's something genuinely new going
on
you could still characterize it as
inference maybe you could characterize
all learning as inference but there's
something learning like here right well
actually so that allows me to say that
when I get to neuroscience which I will
I'm going to talk about some tasks that
don't involve this this really strong
form of novelty and there it's that it
does feel like a little bit of a push to
call the call it learning to learn but I
hope you'll see that computationally the
issues are all pretty much underlying ly
the same and I'll come back and make
some comments about how how we could
push this the idea is I'm going to
present
further until they really feel like
they're engaging something we'd want to
call learning if I can get to that again
okay so so the question I want to
address in discussing your own research
is how in the world can we get systems
like this which are doing amazing things
but aren't sample efficient to do things
like Harlow's monkeys we're able to do
where they leveraged past experience
they extract abstractions that capture
the structure of a task domain and then
apply those efficiently when nominally
new situations are presented how can we
get learning to learn what do we have to
add to architectures like this and the
answer that I'm gonna that I'm gonna
argue for is nothing we don't have to
add anything
in fact these architectures are
perfectly fine at doing learning to
learn you just have to put them in the
right situations so let me explain what
I mean I still in a kind of AI setting
and then I'll move to neuroscience
because my my argument is going to be
that the computational principles I'll
now lay out are potentially relevant to
understanding the brain so I said you
don't have to add anything but there are
there are two things two ingredients you
have to have these are ingredients we
already sometimes use and they don't
involve any technological innovation but
they are nonetheless critical one is you
have to use systems with memory in the
work that I'm going to describe that
involves basically using rather ordinary
recurrent neural networks but
essentially any architecture that
involves memory will do and I'll come
back to this and the second key
ingredient is that it's not enough to
train a deep reinforcement learning
system on one task and expect it to show
the kind of interesting transfer effects
that I was just describing instead you
have to train a system on a bunch of
tasks and I and critically you have to
train the system on a bunch of tasks
that differ on the surface but that that
share some underlying statistical
commonality and I'll give concrete
examples of this as we go along so
before I dive in on the specifics I just
want
knowledge that the ideas that I'm going
to be talking about were introduced in
large part in a classic paper by hawk
rider and colleagues they addressed
supervised learning and I'm going to be
describing applications to reinforcement
learning which I think arguably involves
genuinely new issues and an Hawk rider
didn't talk about the brain but there is
a definite intellectual debt here and I
want to just make sure to acknowledge
that okay so how can recurrent neural
networks in multi task environments
spontaneously give rise to the kind of
learning to learn phenomena that we've
we've we've isolated so I'm going to use
this diagram as we go along
this is meant to represent a multi-layer
perceptron just a bunch of input units a
hidden layer and a bunch of output units
and these are the the internal or hidden
units um the inputs and the outputs are
important so the officer one input will
be some kind of observation of the
environment which in some simulations
will be pixel level inputs like those
that were involved in the examples I
gave earlier sometimes it'll just be a
simple one hot in tasks that really
don't require that kind of visual
observation importantly however there
are others so the system will need to
know what it did on the last time step
what was the last action it performed so
you can think about this as a form of
corollary discharge and also importantly
the system needs to know what reward it
got on the last time step so these may
seem like rather particular demands for
the way we set up our architecture but
in fact when I say the system needs to
know what reward it got on the last time
staff that could just mean that you know
the system recognizes the taste of juice
you know if it's a if we're modeling a
monkey in an experiment where juice is
their ORD on the output side we'll have
an action this is going to be
reinforcement learning model and also as
a highly conventional measure we're
going to have the system emitting an
estimate of the state value so this is
going to be for those of you familiar
with actor critic or a3c
a version of that from deep mind that's
what we're doing here critically these
internal or hidden units are going to
connect with one another and making the
thing a recurrent neural network and
that's where the system is endowed with
memory and then we're going to train the
system using back propagation through
time but importantly we're going to do
that in a reinforcement learning setting
so we're going to use a 3c a version of
reinforced with an actor critic like
baseline for those of you aren't
familiar with those labels for
algorithms just think reinforcement
learning and we can we can talk about
the details offline if you're interested
so let me give you an initial
illustration of what that simple
recurrent neural network architecture
does when you put it in a multi task
environment and we're gonna use a very
simple form of multi task environment
just starting with bandit problems so
we'll start with a two-armed bandit that
has it's a beta Bernoulli bandit the the
arm the payoff parameters for the two
arms are drawn from a simple
distribution and the the agent the
recurrent Network deals with this task
for a set number of trials say you know
50 trials on each step it chooses
whether it wants left to right sees what
happens and moves on to the next trial
so it has to solve the explore exploit
problem that's inherent in in bandit
problems in RL in general but then
critically after we've given it those
fixed number of trials with on that
bandit problem will realize reinitialize
the activities and the network and we'll
give it another bandit problem with the
parameters again randomly sampled and
after that we'll give it another bandit
problem and so forth and so on so what
happens after you've trained a network
on a sufficient number of bandit
problems of this kind and then you give
it a new bandit problem well I'm about
to show you but there's one important
point I want to make so to guide
interpretation of the results I'm going
to show and that is that at tests we're
gonna turn off reinforcement warrant
reinforcement learning we're gonna set
the learning rate on the reinforcement
learning algorithm that's adjusting the
weights in the network to zero so any
learning that's evident in the network's
behavior can't be attributed to weight
changes or synaptic changes if you want
to
think of the analogy that way it's all
reflective of the activity dynamics of
the recurrent neural network okay so
that's a critical point so what we see
is illustrated here so in this red box
is an indication of what happens on an
individual trial in an easy bandit
problem
dark blue means left light blue means
right the network tries a tries left
then it tries right then it tries left
and after that it settles on on on right
which in this case is the right answer
and you can see across trials which
arose here it gets the right answer
almost every time when the task is
harder that is to say you're giving it a
bandit with parameters that are closer
together
it explores for longer but then
eventually settles in to the right quest
the right answer here this is the same
Network just given two different bandit
problems and if you look at the the
performance of the network on a fixed
fixed bandit problem and look at its
cumulative regret it turns out that the
networks doing a very good job of
managing the Explorer exploit dilemma
it's it's regret curve is you know
comparable to what you see it doesn't
quite match kittens but it's actually
better than what you get from
off-the-shelf algorithms like Thompson
sampling to meet with some measure to
just alternate in the beginning to get
an estimate and
yes that's right it depends on the
payoffs and that's the critical thing so
you can actually if you get unlucky and
the payoffs that you get which are of
course stochastic seem to suggest that
the right arm is left when in fact it's
right you may spend some time dwelling
on the left when an omniscient viewer
knows you shouldn't have done that but
that's the point of these these curves
Gittens is the is the proven optimal for
beethoven you li get bandits and we we
don't quite match it but we come close
I'll talk more about strategy in a
second so again what I'm showing you
here is the performance of a network
with no weight changes going on it's all
the dynamics of it's all the activity
dynamics so what's happened here is that
the reinforcement learning algorithm
that's adjusting the weights is the main
effect of that learning is to adjust the
dynamic the activity dynamics of their
current network so that eventually those
those recurrent dynamics themselves
implement a learning algorithm so and
that can be executed without any weight
changes so you can look you can you can
get a sense of how this learning
algorithm this kind of meddler this this
acquired learning algorithm operates by
doing dimensionality reduction
visualizations on the hidden state of
the network over the course of these
bandit problems and this will come back
to what I was just saying about
trajectories so you know in a problem
that we're that's very easy and the
correct answer is on the left what you
find is that the the hidden state of the
network follows a trajectory toward one
attractor in a very smooth way if the
correct answer is on the other side and
the problem is easy you again see what
looks very much like a tractor dynamics
if the problem is harder then sometimes
you'll see reversals where the network
will kind of head in one direction and
then double back and correct itself
later so what we're seeing here in
action is an acquired learning algorithm
that's different from the one that was
was programmed by hand and that is
expressed at the level of the activity
dynamics rather than in the connection
weights yes
so this is an it's an LS TM I should
have mentioned that so it can it can
remember just about as far back as your
back propagation window goes and we were
liberal with that in this in these
simulations so we gave it a large enough
backdrop window that it could that the
the gradients could go back to critical
events in in in in the early in the
earlier time series but that's something
that one might want to think about
unless kind of Machiavellian ways if
when we're trying to model biological
data yes this is a really clear
illustration of the bifurcation and kind
of strategy according to how the
statistics work out but it seems the
example was a little bit toy compared to
the real world absolutely good
absolutely bad what I don't know that
outside trees and grass ever gives you
such and such unambiguous answers does
this also do interesting and useful
things in the continuous from what's not
you mean continuous action spaces real
brains move in a continuous world so I'm
wondering have you looked I've got lots
of other examples and once I've gone
through them maybe raise your hand again
and tell me which ones were satisfying
or which or whether you're still looking
for something yeah this is clearly just
an initial illustration but I think it
is important to defend bandit problems
as as interesting certainly they've
occupied control theory for years here's
something about bandit problems that's
to me even more interesting and
interesting and exciting anyway I just
want to check I have until quarter of
yeah okay great
so I I've already said that the way I
think about what's going on here is that
you have the hand coded reinforcement
learning algorithm and then you have
what's I think legitimately called a
learned learning algorithm or an
acquired learning out of the Guru of
them which is expressed in the dynamics
and one cool thing is that that acquired
learning algorithm needn't have any of
the properties of the original learning
algorithm and in general it will be
quite different and in particular it
will be fit to the statistics of the
domain in which the system was trained
so the first example I gave involved
bethe Bernoulli bandits which means that
the parameters on the two arms were were
independent they were sampled iid they
were sampled independent of one another
across episodes but now let's imagine
that instead of doing that we fix things
so that the parameters on the arms vary
across episodes but they're they're
perfectly anti-correlated so I choose a
Bernoulli parameter for one arm and then
I just set the other one to one -
whatever that parameter is this is a
much easier problem to solve because
what you learn about one arm implies
something about the other arm which is
not true in the beta Bernoulli case and
what we find is that the network
capitalizes on that so it shows much
lower regret suggesting that it has
tuned in to these statistics and and is
getting away with with with with with
lower regret it's it's picking the right
action more efficiently because it has
it's it's learning algorithm it's
exploration strategy exploits the
structure that's there yeah so the the
actually the black lines there are no
longer really relevant because they only
apply to the beta Bernoulli case the the
important distinction is between the red
curve and the blue curve which are both
generated by my recurrent Network and
the fact that the fact that the blue
curve is as leveling out sooner means
that it's finding the right answer
sooner it's it is that we're asking
always the red curve ever leveling out
rate there are there are cases
especially when the bandit problem is
hard that the network decides on the
wrong answer and sticks with it which is
which is also true of
many high-performing hand-coded
algorithms so because if the if you if
you get very unlucky and you get you get
data that suggests that the left arm is
right when in fact the right arm is
right you might you might end up
sampling the the best arm very rarely
and that that's it's just because this
is an average over trials does that make
sense
okay cool all right okay good so
hopefully you've all got the the idea
now let's let's just apply this to a
bunch of stuff and let's start with
Harlow's task so in order to do this in
deep mind style we we came up with
visual inputs that that were pixel based
and they looked exactly like this this
is exactly what the network got just at
a lower lower resolution it's a
simulated video screen with two objects
between which the agent had to choose by
saccade and left or right and the
objects here are just patches of of
image net images six trials with the
same two images one of them was good one
of them was bad and then two new images
were chosen and so forth so it's exactly
like Carlos tasks and what we find is
that this rather ordinary recurrent
neural network here augmented just with
a front-end to do some visual processing
or a convolutional neural network
behaves exactly like Harlow's animals so
after a significant amount of experience
when it's presented with two completely
new image patches that it's never dealt
with before it chooses one at random and
then after that it knows what the what
the good image is okay so now let's
let's pivot to two neuroscience because
as we were doing this work the idea
impressed itself more and more upon me
that there were things here that
reminded me of of things that I had been
taught about the brain and we decided to
explore that and so the the I'm going to
tell you now about that work which I'm
pleased to say has just been accepted at
Nature Neuroscience so we'll have a
report out about that soon and we
actually just put in on archive if
anybody wants to check out the details
ahead of that
yeah yeah yes no that's not true that's
not true no so you you there you our
procedure as we real it reinitialize the
activities of the hidden units the the
weights in the network are frozen right
but the weights in the network oh ok
sorry ok I think I see what you're
saying in other words Oh between
presentations are the same two objects
yes ok
yes thank you that is true and so I'm
gonna explain the neuroscience
perspective on this but let me just
bookmark that by saying that the system
that I'm going to describe if you
interpret it in a neuroscientific
context operates a little bit like a
hippocampal amnesia so as long as things
as long as it's keeping things active in
working memory it can apply past
experience to present action but the
minute you distract it for a second it
can't bring that you can't bring that
back and that's something that we've
we've rectified in in recent work so I
can I can I'll touch on that right at
the end but we've basically augmented
the system with an episodic memory and
it can handle that sort of thing now you
know you know in what I think is a
psychologically and biologically
interesting way but I can talk to you
more about that
okay so pivoting to neuroscience we
already have a link because there are
many people who are convinced that the
temporal difference or prediction error
from reinforcement learning has
something to do with phasic dopaminergic
signaling in the brain so we'll just
take that on board and and think of this
red arrow which is tuning the weights in
this system as in terms of biological
learning driven by dopamine but the
other thing that we're going to do
that's my eye con for dopamine the other
thing we're going to do is we're going
to think about the recurrent Network
itself and its activity dynamics as
relating to what we know about the
prefrontal cortex so I'm gonna speak
here globally about the prefrontal
cortex
which of course is absurd because we
know there are many important regional
differences within that structure I'm
also going to say I'm going to include
the circuits the recurrent circuits that
run from the prefrontal cortex through
its subcortical associates in the
thalamus and basal ganglia again an
absurd level of abstraction however I'm
certain I'm not the first and not even
the first in this room to undertake to
think about the way that the prefrontal
cortex works by studying the behavior of
rather simple recurrent neural networks
and this is a strategy that we've seen
pay off in past research and hopefully
it will do so here so yeah so we're
gonna think about dopamine as analogous
to the to the reinforcement learning
algorithm that's tuning the system
weights and we're gonna think about the
recurrent dynamics as something that the
prefrontal cortex is implementing in the
brain okay
so armed with that set of analogies can
we take this system and apply it to
experimental findings for Neuroscience
and gain any insight and so in the paper
that I mentioned we we have a series of
nine simulations which address a very
diverse set of phenomena and I'm just
gonna speed through a subset of those to
give you a flavor of what what we're up
to and hopefully given the the preceding
discussion you'll be in a position to
get the gist and then I'm happy to go
into any details people in here so let's
start with something very much like a
bandit task that's been studied in the
monkey neurophysiology literature and
focus on this great paper by sue sue E
and colleagues from a couple years ago
the idea here is that a monkey is given
two visual targets it has two saccade
two one or the other and across trials
this being a bandit task those two
visual targets are associated particular
payoff schedules and critically as in
our toy bandit example these payoff
parameters are changing across testing
sessions so the monkey has to figure out
what's going on in any testing session
and and concentrate its behavior on the
option that has the greater payoff this
is behavioral data from from the
experimental study and an interesting
side note is that given the payoff
probabilities in this task
sure of the reward schedule actually it
was not the optimal strategy to choose
one option and just stick with it that
is maximizing in that sense was not the
right strategy but rather it's a better
idea to do something called probability
matching where you match your sampling
rate for each target to the to a measure
that's related to the number of payoffs
you've gotten on that side so as the the
the the ratio of rewards received
changes across across training sessions
so does the the the percentage of
choices from one option to the other we
train this recurrent neural network same
architecture I described before on
exactly this task and we get exactly the
same behavior the red dots here are just
held out held held out parameters so the
system interpolates in a satisfying way
one interesting thing though is that
this is the same network that was
maximizing on the beta Bernoulli bandits
so not only is it doing something that
looks like what the monkeys are doing
but it's also spontaneously figured out
that the right strategy here is
different from the one in there in the
Bandit task we described before okay
that's just a behavioral effect though
yes where does the noise come from well
the the payoffs are stochastic so to
some extent that's well I think that
well not just to some extent I think
that is literally the only source of
noise in this task right so that so for
each drug for each action there's a
stochastic payoff so the monkey can be
fooled just as as it can be fooled in a
beta Bernoulli bandit task okay right
this trains from scratch train from
scratch that's right but it's an example
of where the learned learning algorithm
is fit to the statistics of the domain
all right so recall that in these
simulations at test time we're holding
the weights of the system fixed so we
don't think that's what's going on in a
monkey but it helps us interpret the
behavior of the model because we know by
construction that any learning that we
see in the in the artificial system has
reflect its activity dynamics not its
weight changes and for that for that
reason we're able to go inside that
hidden layer and look at how the latent
representation is evolving and find out
something about how the network is doing
what it's doing and this is a nice thing
to be able to do in the context of this
soui study because that's that he was
actually an electrophysiology experiment
where they looked specifically at what
prefrontal neurons were doing during the
course of performing this task and what
they found was that there were neurons
that coded for a variety of quantities
during during performance of this task
one was simply what what choice the
animal was about to make but more
interestingly there were neurons that
coded for the value of that choice in an
anticipatory way and then perhaps most
interesting there were neurons that
seemed to be keeping track of the
history of actions and reward outcomes
and this is just a histogram that shows
the proportion of neurons in their data
that coded for these different things so
what's going on in our network well to
some extent well so when we look at
what's being what's being represented by
the the units in our hidden layer it's
exactly the same variables in a way this
is a like a Navia it had to be this way
otherwise it would be deeply mysterious
how the network is doing what it's doing
it's doing reinforcement learning which
means it has to keep track of recent
action outcome history and the only way
it can do that is in its activity
patterns since we're holding the weights
constant we can again go under the hood
and look at at how these representations
evolve as we did before but I'm not
gonna take the time to go into the
results but you can get the gist so this
is an initial example of how we can
apply this meta reinforcement learning
idea to neural data and what we end up
with from this and other simulations I'm
about to tell you about is an idea that
actually the recurrent dynamics that
come out of the loops of the connect the
loops within prefrontal cortex and
perhaps running through its associated
subcortical regions it's the activity
dynamics that are driving learning and
tasks like the one that Sosua studied
how
for those that those dynamics are shaped
by dopamine over longer timescales
that's the that's the the neuroscience
version of this meta reinforcement
learning story that I introduced in more
abstract terms before now I made a big
deal of this the fact that this learned
learning algorithm will exploit or will
be fit to the statistics of the training
domain and now I want to present another
simulation of a neuroscience study that
I think gets at that idea so there's a
very nice study from 2007 by Tim Behrens
and colleagues where they looked at
human performance on a task where there
were it's a bandit task and there were
periods during which the parameters of
the task remain constant he referred to
these as stable periods and then there
were periods where the parameters flip
back and forth rapidly referred to these
as volatile periods and he used model
fitting to infer the affective learning
rate involved in the human subjects
behavioural adjustments and found that
during stable periods the learning rate
would would fall to low relatively low
levels and then during the volatile
periods the learning rate would bump up
to a higher level and he showed with an
ideal observer model that this was a
smart thing to do
and what we find with our meta RL system
is exactly the same thing so you train
the network on bandit problems that go
through stable periods and that go
through volatile periods and then you
you look at its behavior and you use a
little bit it's a little bit recursive
but you use a reinforcement learning
model to infer its affective learning
rate and what you find is that the
learning algorithm that is in bet that
is embedded in its activity dynamics
moves to a low learning rate during
stable periods and a high learning rate
during volatile periods which is
something that of course was not at all
involved in the RL algorithm that was
used to Train the weights in the system
so here again we have an example of the
acquired RL algorithm that's expressed
in the dynamics absorbing properties of
the training domain fitting itself to
two properties of the particular domain
at which in which is trained I'm going
to skip that
okay so one what let me talk about one
more simulation so the examples that
I've given so far focused on prefrontal
activation I skipped over a slide
showing that as in Tim Behrens study
where they found neurons coding for
volatility in prefrontal cortex we also
find that internet work those are
studies about that address prefrontal
phenomena but we can also address
findings relating to dopamine with this
system and I'll just give you one
example of this so here's a here's a
simple and elegant result that has been
considered to be rather challenging or
puzzling from the point of view of
standard models of how dopamine works to
drive learning this is from a study by
Bromberg Martin and colleagues so here
monkey was given either a left target or
a right target and this wasn't a choice
to ask the monkey was just expected to
saccade to the given target but the key
the key manipulation was that in some
blocks the the left target would be
followed by a juice reward and in other
blocks the right target would be
followed by that reward and and and it
was only ever one target that was
rewarded and critically the monkey had
to the monkey wasn't these changes
weren't signaled so the monkey would be
going along it would be rewarded for
left and then all of a sudden without
warning things would switch and now it
would be the right the right target
that's rewarded so the monkey if it
wanted to be able to predict what was
going to happen just had to kind of keep
track of recent events and and
critically had to understand the
structure of the task so another
sometimes it would reverse so the
critical finding and the study had to do
with dopamine and so let's let's
consider a scenario in which left has
been rewarded for a while and now the
monkey sees a left target well what's
going to happen when you measure domme
energic activity the classic story tells
you that you should see a burst at that
point and in fact that's what they
observed but the critical question is
what happens when a reversal occurs so
the monkeys going along it's rewarded
for left and then it sees a left and
then it's not rewarded for that what
happens on the very next trial
right after we reversal well if the
monkey sees that same target again so
it's all left it thought it was going to
be rewarded and then it wasn't now in
the next trial as he's left
dopamine does not spike in fact there's
a little bit of a dip which which
indicates that the system has like gets
it there was a reversal but so far
there's nothing deeply mysterious going
on because the monkey already had an
experience of non reward with this
target the really cool thing is what
happens if you're rewarded for left
rewarded for left and then all of us
have not rewarded for left and on the
next trial you get a right and what
Robert Martin and colleagues showed was
that you see a you see a reversal for
dopaminergic activity even for that case
so there's a reversal that's that's
signaled by an outcome for one target
and then on the next trial the other
target occurs and dopamine is making the
right prediction which suggests a form
of structure of learning or latent state
inference which isn't part it's not an
inherent part of the classical dopamine
story it turns out that if you just
train our recurrent neural network or
matter RL system on this on this task
structure and then look at the roar'd
prediction errors it emits it does
exactly the same thing so it does this
kind of I think brumberg Martin
colleagues called this the inferred
value effect and and our model shows
exactly the same thing why well it's
easy to figure that out when you look at
the architecture the hidden state of the
network is keeping track of the latent
state of the task based on recent
outcomes that hidden state is being used
to compute the state value the state
value is of course being used to compute
the reward prediction error and so of
course the reward prediction errors
reflect these latent state inferences
okay so just to wrap up I showed before
examples of how we can understand
prefrontal circuits implementing
reinforcement learning algorithms that
are shaped over time by dopaminergic
function what I've just showed you
suggests also that things can go the
other way with prefrontal
representations affecting the way that
dopamine operates and for those of you
know the literature you recognize
there's already a good deal of evidence
for that there are other simulations I
don't have time to tell you about one
that shows how model-based RL can come
out of model free RL another that
addresses
from the optogenetic literature but just
to sum up let's come back to the main
theme which was this learning to learn a
fact or kind of a demand for sample
efficiency and I hope I've communicated
at least a theory for how we can get
this from what are actually now fairly
standard deep RL systems by just putting
them in the right kind of environments
and get from that some new ideas about
how dopamine the prefrontal cortex may
interact so just a couple of closing
slides there's much more to do in both
on both the AI front and the
neuroscience front mainly to see how we
can scale these these kinds of
principles up my interest isn't seeing
how that they can apply in semantically
richer and richer context hopefully
aiming for things like like frostbite
like video game play and we're looking
at ways of doing that including ways of
biasing architecture rather than using
these vanilla recurrent neural networks
using what we know about how to kind of
nudge deep learning systems in the right
direction to learn interesting things
there are other forms of meta learning
that might dovetail with this like
architecture search for those of you
familiar with that and I mentioned in
response to a question earlier that
bringing in episodic memory as a way of
bridging longer temporal gaps is is
another thing that we've been working on
and I just want to mention you know I
was excited to see the lineup of
speakers because there are there are a
number of talks coming our way later on
in fact one one of them that immediately
follows mine that are gonna raise look
at topics that are germane to the the
computational schemas I've been laying
out here and I'm looking forward to
thinking through the implications myself
and talking with everyone about it
finally I just want to mention that you
know I think this project provides a
nice illustration of how work in AI and
work in neuroscience can synergize
forming what at deep mind we like to
call a virtuous circle each field
helping the other and then finally I
just want to acknowledge my
collaborators and in particular gene
Wong ends up Chris Nelson who did a lot
of the modeling that I've described
thank you
[Applause]
okay well I mean that story can only be
told from a first-person perspective but
I certainly when I started out on this
bit of work was not thinking about
reinforcement learning in the brain in
these terms
so and in in work I think she may may
tell us about had already been doing
work on the role of working memory in
reinforcement learning and that seemed
right to me
but it hadn't occurred to me to think
about working memory circuits being
tuned by dopaminergic learning and
certainly it hadn't occurred to me that
the result might be a learning algorithm
that's quite different from from the one
that's that's that's involved in in
dopaminergic learning so at least for me
personally starting out with some
computational questions and then
realizing halfway through that these
could map on to brain circuits was a
useful useful exercise so just to
challenge a little bit so you said
basically about deep learning is good
enough and I would argue what you showed
us here is really
well you basically try to use the same
rules and you change out some parameters
but how do you want to extend this to
really challenging okay so so one thing
that I found myself saying once we were
deep into this work to my colleagues was
meta learning or learning to learn is
really only as interesting as the
abstractions that are being acquired so
in an abandoned problem the abstraction
is well there are two parameters and I
you know can at least implicitly
understand what the distributions are
that they're you know from which they're
drawn in the correlated bandit problem I
mentioned the abstraction is it has to
do with the anti correlation itself in
the harlow task there's there's a more
interesting form of abstraction which is
there's one good thing and one bad thing
and I need to know that I can take two
completely new objects and fit them into
those those roles so already we're into
the realm of no it's not a question of
exchange it's a question of of binding
like like of rapid binding right you've
got objects you've never seen before but
I don't I'm not sure I see a line you
know a roadblock where we're network
we're gonna we're gonna hit a wall and
we're not going to be able to move to
richer forms of abstraction in other
words I think the challenge is to find
tasks domains where what's very where
you have tasks that very superficially
but then involve interesting forms of
shared structure and that's a that's a
very hard thing to build and I think
that actually is gonna be one of the
challenges in this in this research but
so one thing that we're doing now at D
mind just to give you a sense of where
this is headed is building built this
when you finish the sense that coming up
with ways of procedurally generating
video games so that you you can play a
thousand games in which there's an
avatar and there are particular kinds of
events that it can occur and then you
can sample a new video game where
nothing's the same on the surface but
there are some concepts you may have to
apply like
I know their enemies I know that I can
change one thing into another by
bringing a tool in contact with in that
sort of thing sorry you were going to go
on since you was a neuroscientist I
wonder what is your motivation for doing
this to what extent we should in this
direction I early on I I talked to a guy
named alex pj about what we were doing
here and he asked me this question is
this about learning or is it about
inference and I I ended up just deciding
I was unable to answer that question
because I'm not sure what the difference
is so because I have that attitude now
I'm not sure how to sort those two
things across synaptic change and
activity but having said that I
certainly think we know the difference
between learning and inference when we
see it right and this comes back also I
think to the question that was just
raised about like how can you scale this
up to her like really interesting forms
of transfer so that's the best I can do
because I don't I don't I'm not sure I
even know how to frame an answer that
would be satisfying to me one thing I'll
add though and this cut this also
circles back a little bit to the
question it was just raised is I think
that these mechanisms can extend to
quite rich forms of inference that
really would deserve the label
conceptual you know conceptual inference
however I don't expect back propagation
through time in totally unstructured
networks to find the right weights to do
those those things so I think what we're
going to need is more interesting
architectures that it effectively impose
architectural biases on the you know on
the solutions that the network finds and
therefore on the forms of inference that
you'll see so I think I think my
colleague Greg Greg Wayne might talk
about architectures that have properties
that are along those lines
thank you
[Applause]